Collecting data and
tracking metrics can be tricky.
So, here are some tips and awesome
tools for how to go about that process.
First is Google Analytics.
It's great for getting stats on traffic.
You can see demographics, user devices,
and browser types inversions.
It's a bit more exploratory in nature,
but
you can quickly get data on page
views and click through rates.
You do want to be careful because
oftentimes the data does not show
unique users.
Analytics can be messy, so it's good
to reproduce the numbers in two tools.
Mixpanel is another great tool
to measure user activities.
It's particularly great for
measuring drop off in a funnel.
You can build customer funnels to
determine if students drop off at step
one step two, or step three of any
process or sequence of behaviors.
It's also useful for
measuring retention.
Now, you will need to be deliberate
about instrumenting events
that you want to track
when using the tool.
This forces you to get clear about what
you want to know about your users.
If you come across big differences when
using two tools like Google Analytics
and Mixpanel, you want to dig deep to
determine which value is more reliable
and what might be
driving this difference.
If you're building an app,
AdMob is another excellent
tool to add to your arsenal.
It offers many features,
such as flows to the application,
user exit points, and ways to
automatically maximize add revenue.
If you're looking to conduct surveys,
you might use tools such as Qualtrics.
They're a popular solution for MPS.
You might also try SurveyMonkey or
Google forms.
Once you have a user base and
feel like you have a core product,
you can optimize around smaller changes
in your website, such as layout,
headlines, button colors, and images.
This is called the A/B testing and
Optimizely is one tool that
let's you do this easily.
Now, A/B testing isn't the best
way to go, and certainly,
not when you're first starting out.
Up next, Pete from Optimizely will
discuss why this is in more detail.